موجات من المسيرات في طريقها لاستهداف
كياف ورئيس البلديه يؤكد ان انظمه الدفاع
المضاده للطائرات تتصدى لها
رفض سعودي امريكي لانتهاكات الهدنه في
السودان في مواطن تعلن اجراءات عقابيه ضد
الجيش والدعم السريع
مجلس الشيوخ يقر قانون رفع سقف الدين
يتطلع للمصادقه النهائيه عليه هو التحدث
للشعب الامريكي اليوم
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم
اعلنت السلطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بان
انظمه الدفاع المضاده للطائرات في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
نشطت في وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم في محاوله
لصد هجمات روسيه وقال رئيس بلديه كيا
فيتالي كليتشكو بان ان انفجارات عده دوت
في العاصمه كييف وان موجه جديده من
الطائرات المسيره تتجه نحو المدينه فيما
تعمل الدفاعات الجويه لصدي تلك الهجمات
هذا واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن مقتل
15 مسلحا اوكرانيا حاولوا دخول الاراضي
الروسيه عن طريق الضفه اليسرى لنهر دنياسك
الدفاع الروسيه اوضحت بان مقتل المسلحين
الاوكرانيين جاء عن طريق حقل الغام مشيره
بان الدفاع الروسيه قضت ايضا على بقايا
المجموعه المسلحه موضحه في الوقت ذاته بان
الضفه اليمنى من النهر شهدت ايضا مجموعه
اوكرانيه اخرى قضي عليها على حد وصفها
في بدايه ما يوم هذا العام هاجم الطائرات
مسيره مبنى وسط موسكو استنفرت القوات
الروسيه وسرع الرئيس الاوكراني
لا نهاجم بوتين او موسكو نحن نحارب في
ارضنا وندافع عن وطننا
هذه المره لا شيء يمكن اخفاؤه او نفيه
موسكو تحت القصف
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه قالت انها تحتفظ
بحق الرد بينما خرج الرئيس الروسي هادئا
يتحدث عن تعزيز دفاعات حول العاصمه
انظمه موسكو المضاده للصواريخ عملت كما
ينبغي رغم ان هناك اشياء يجب تحسينها لقد
واجهنا بالفعل نفس المشكله في قاعده حميم
الجويه في سوريا على الرغم من انه لا
يمكنك مقارنه قاعدتنا الجويه في حميم
بموسكو هذه مدينه اوروبيه ضخمه لكن بشكل
عام نحن نفهم ما يتعين علينا القيام به
لتعزيز نظام عاصمتنا المضاد للصواريخ
وسنفعل ذلك
دول اوروبيه انتشر الدفع لثاني اقوى قوه
عسكريه في العالم مؤكده ان ما تقدمه من
اسلحه مخصص للدفاع وليس لنقل المعركه داخل
روسيا
اخر مره تعرضت فيها موسكو لقصف حقيقي كان
في اربعينيات القرن الماضي خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بينما تعرضت نيويورك
لقصف بالطائرات في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
عام 2001 ردت عليها الولايات المتحده
بحروب قتل فيها اكثر من خمسه ملايين انسان
شيخ ختام القمه التي عقدتها المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه في مولدوفا قال الرئيس
الفرنسي عمانيان ماكرون ان بلاده ستواصل
دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه لتمكينها من شن
هجوم مضاد على القوات الروسيه فيما شدد
الرئيس فولوديميرز على ضروره ان تحصل
بلاده على ضمانات امنيه ليست فقط من اجلها
وحدها بل من اجل الدول المجاوره لها والتي
قد تتعرض احداها وخصوصا مولدوفا للعدوان
الروسي كانت اول لقمه دوليه تعقد في
مولدوفا البلد الصغير والمتصدر للائحه
الدول الافقر في اوروبا وكانت اول قمه
اوروبيه تعقد في بلد ليس عضوا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الهدف ارسال رساله قويه الى
روسيا مفادها ان مولدوفا ليست وحدها كما
قال قاده اوروبيون تعاقبوا على الكلام طلب
زيلينسكي ضمانات امنيه وقال ان الوقت قد
حان لاتخاذ قرارات واضحه
اعتقد ان الضمانات الامنيه مهمه جدا ليس
فقط من اجل اوكرانيا بل ايضا من اجل
جيرانها ومن اجل مولدوفا واحتمالات
العدوان على مولدوفا واجزاء اخرى من
اوروبا الرئيس الفرنسي قال ان بلاده
ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا لتمكينها من
شن الهجوم المضاد على روسيا
اعتقد ان قمه المقبل يجب ان تبعث برساله
واضحه الى اوكرانيا والاوكرانيين وقد
اتفقت مع الرئيس زيلينسكي على مواصله دعم
بلاده بالاسلحه كانت قمه
مناسبه للقاء جمع ايضا كلا من الرئيس
الفرنسي ومستشار المانيا برئيس وزراء
ارمينيا والرئيس الادربيجاني كما التقى
ماكرون رئيسه وزراء كوسوفو والرئيس الصربي
داعيا بعد اللقاء الى تطبيق خطه فرنسيه
المانيه لتهدئه التوترات في كوسوفو ابرزت
هذه القمه تباين المواقف بين الاوروبيين
داخل الاتحاد وخارجه الى حد الاختلاف
احيانا وان حافظوا على وحده ظاهريه من
بريطانيا المؤيده لهجمات اوكرانيا في
العمق الروسي الى هولندارك المتحمسه
لتدريب طيارين اوكرانيين مرورا بالمانيا
غير المتحمسه لانضمام الى حلف الناتو
ووصولا الى فرنسا التي تحاول بصعوبه
التوفيق بين دعمها المتردد لزلانسكي
ورغبتها الضمنيه في لحظه حوار متجدده مع
بوتين العربيه
[موسيقى]
والولايات المتحده عن قلقهما من
الانتهاكات الجسيمه لوقف النار في السودان
كما اعلن بيان سعوديه امريكي عن تعليق
مفاوضات الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع لعدم جديه الطرفين وفق ما اشار
البيان واكدت السعوديه والولايات المتحده
بانه وبمجرد ان تتضح جديه طرفي الصراع
سيكون هناك استعداد لمناقشه حل تفوضي
واشار البيان الى ان الانتهاكات في
السودان غدرت بالمدنيين وب ايصال
المساعدات لهم وحثت السعوديه والولايات
المتحده طرفي الصراع على الالتزام بجديه
وقف النار
في الاثناء فرضت واشنطن عقوبات اقتصاديه
على طرفي الصراع في السودان كما منعت
التاشيرات عنهم وشملت العقوبات اربع شركات
تابعه لجهات عسكريه تغذي طرفي الصراع بحسب
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه من جهه قلم
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي بان فشل وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان سيزيد مخاوف
واشنطن من صراع طويل الامد كما سيزيد من
معاناه المدنيه السودان
في السودان وقف اطلاق النار هاشون للغايه
هناك مخاطر كبيره تحيط بالسودانيين
ومازلنا بعيدين جدا عن التوصل لهدنه
حقيقيه وهذا ليس من مصلحه احد هذا العنف
يجب ان يتوقف ونحن نراقب ونعرف ان الطرفي
الصراع انتهك التزاماتهما وهذا لا يجب ان
يمضي بدون حساب ننظر في خطوات يمكننا
اتخاذها لتوضيح وجهات نظرنا حيال اي زعماء
يقودون السودان في الاتجاه الخاطئ
عرض امريكي باستئناف جهود وقف النار في
السودان بيد انه مرهون بجديه الطرفي
النزاع في الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كشرط
اساسي وفق ما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه واشنطن اعربت عن اسافها من قرار
الجيش السوداني وقف المحادثات معتبره ان
الخطوه تصاعب وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السودانيين
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات
الخطوه جاءت بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الجيش من جانبه اوضح
ان تعليق مشاركته في محادثات جده مع الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه بسبب عدم
التزام قوات الدعم السريع ببنود الهدنه
واتهمها بالفشل في الايفاء بالتزاماتها
كما راى انه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديد
الهدنه في ظل الخروق التي ترتكبها قوات
الدعم السريع
اما قوات الدعم السريع فقد اكدت التزامها
بالمفاوضات مشيره الى ان الجيش تعمد تعطيل
الهدنه
على الارض دوي اطلاق النار لا يتوقف في
مناطق متفرقه بالخرطوم والولايات
والوضع الانساني يمضي من سيء الى اسوا
راس العربيه بان قوه مشتركه من الحركات
المسلحه الموقعه على اتفاق سلام جوبا نقلت
العشرات من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه واغلب
هؤلاء من الاتراك والاثيوبيين والايطاليين
من مدينه نيالا جنوب اقليم دارفور الى
مدينه الفاشر شملها ووفقا لحاكم دارفور
فان الترتيبات تجرى حاليا لنقلهم برا من
دارفور الى بورتسودان شرقي السودان وفق
الخطه الموضوعه وذكر بان الرعايه الذين
وصلوا الفاشر سيكون تحت حمايه ورعايه
القوه المشتركه في دارفور
في السياق تمكنت كاميرا العربيه من الدخول
الى مطار الخرطوم الدولي حيث وثقت حجم
الدمار جراء المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
اهلا بكم نحن الان داخل مطار الخرطوم
الدولي الذي دارت فيه الاشتباكات منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم دارت هذه
الاشتباكات وخلفت كثير من الدمار والخراب
ندخل الان الى صاله المغادره وهذه هي
الصاله الاساسيه التي كان يعبر من خلالها
الكثيرين الى وجهات العالم المختلفه نحن
الان داخل الصاله الرئيسيه للمغادره حيث
كان يقف هنا عدد من المسافرين
ويتجمعون لعمليات السفر واجراء عدد من
الاجراءات الرسميه للسفر في هذه في هذا
المكان كان يقف المسافرون
وتتم من خلالها الاجراءات الرسميه المتبعه
في صلاه السفر العالميه تشاهد هذا الدمار
وهذا الخراب الذي لحق بهذا المكان عدد
كبير من السيارات التي كانت تتوقف في مطار
الخرطوم تعرضت للحرق بشكل واضح جراء
الاشتباكات التي دارت منذ الخامس عشر
جبريل نشاهد ذلك من خلال هذه المشاهد وهذه
الصور الحصريه لقناتها العربيه والحدث من
امام صاله الحج والعمره ومن الناحيه
الشرقيه ننظر الى
مهبط الطائرات الرئيسي في مطار العاصمه
الخرطوم بحسب ما نشاهد لم يتضرر جراء
الاشتباكات العسكريه ولكن عدد من الطائرات
شاهدناها محروقه او محترقه بالشكل الكامل
هنا هي صاله الحج والعمره حيث يتجهز كثير
جدا من المعتمرين والحاجين الى بيت الله
الحرام في كل عام ويخرجون من هذه الصاله
الى هذه السيارات التي تقف وتنقل كثير جدا
من
المسافرين الى الطائرات التي كانت تتوقف
في القرب من هذا المكان حتى عدد من
الشركات العامله في مطار الخرطوم نلاحظ ان
عدد من السيارات
محطمه بشكل جزئي وتوقفت بشكل كامل
الجوازات سفر وهواتف نق اله محطمه ولكن
هنا الصاله صاله الحج والعمره ما زالت
بخير لم تتحطم الجراء الاشتباكات العسكريه
التي دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم بعد 47 يوما
من القتال كنا معكم هنا داخل مطار الخرطوم
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار ابو شيبه
[موسيقى]
تتابعنا ولكن بعد قليل
سقوط جديد متكرر للرئيس الامريكي بايدن
خلال مشاركته بحفل تخريج للقوات الجويه
وترامب يعاود السخريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اقرب مجلس شيوخ
الامريكيه قانون رفع سقف الدين باغلبيه 63
صوتا مقابل 36 الى ذلك سارع رئيس بايدن
الى الترحيب بهذه الخطوه الاساسيه وقال في
بيان ان المصادقه على هذا القانون يمثل
انتصارا للاقتصاد وللولايات المتحده بعض
قال انه يتطلع للمصادقه النهائيه على
قانون رفع سقف الدين في اسرع وقت وانه
سيتحدث للشعب الامريكي اليوم بعد المصادقه
عليها
تعرض الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن لحادث
سقوط خلال مشاركته في حفل تخريج القوات
الجويه في اكاديميه سلاح الجو الامريكي في
كولورادو وحادث جديد يطرح تساؤلات حول
الحاله الصحيه للرئيس البالغ من العمر 80
عاما من جانبه قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس
تعثر بكيس رمل لكنه لم يصب باذى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عوده الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن البيت
الابيض ضحك بايدن امام الصحافيين وقال لهم
تعليقا على سقوطه سقوطه لقد وبخوني
[موسيقى]
لقد وضحوني
خلال حدث لتقديم الشكر للمتطوعين في حمله
الانتخابيه للعام 2024 بولايه امريكيه على
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دان ترامب على
حادثه سقوط خلافه الرئيس بايدن في حفل
تخريج القوات الجويه في كولورادو واتمنى
له السلامه
حسنا املوا انه لم يصب باذى اتمنى ان لا
يصاب باذى انظروا الموقف برمته جنون فعليك
ان تكون حذرا على المنصات لانك لا تريد
السقوط عن السلالم حتى لو تطلب الامر
النزول عنها خطوه بخطوه
[موسيقى]
استعادت العاصمه الموريتانيه هدوءها بعد
مظاهرات عنيفه واعمال شغب احتجاجا على
حادثه وفاه مواطن يدعى عمار جوب كان
موقوفا لدى الشرطه وشهدت عدد من مدن
البلاد واحتجاجات مماثله تمت السيطره
عليها بعد اتخاذ اجراءات امنيه مشدده
في مشرحه هذا المستشفى تحجز جثه القتيل
عمر جوب في انتظار صدور تقرير الطب الشرعي
وفي المحيط يتجمع اقارب القتيل مطالبين
بتحقيق شفاف في ظروف وملابسات الوفاه
حادثه وفاه عمار بعد توقيفه لدى الشرطه
تحولت الى قضيه راي عام
احتجاجات واعمال شغب في عدد من احياء
نواكشوط ومدن داخليه يقول الامن ان اجانب
شاركوا فيها ان الدوله بموازاه مع حرصها
التام على احقاق الحق وانفاذ العداله
فانها ستتصدى بحزم وبقوه القانون لكل من
تسول له نفسه المساس بالامن والسكينه
والسلم الاهلي
تراجعت وتيره الاحتجاجات وعاد الهدوء الى
الاحياء التي عرفت عنفها طيله يومين
متتاليين وصاحبتها اعمال سطول ونهب تطلب
اخمادها والسيطره عليها انتشارا امنيا
مكثفا للشرطه وقوات الامن انهارات ما شاء
الله خلق ياسر من الفوضى ولكن
الحمد لله تبارك الله حاله احسن حال ان
شاء الله قطعه من الايام الاثنين مرضى انا
اليوم مريض
على حسب الدخان ولكن مولانا
توقيفه لدى الشرطه الموريتانيه تشبه حادثه
مقتل الناشط الحقيقي الصوفي للشين حتى
للشرطه قبل اشهر والذي وجهت ومت قتله
لثمانيه عناصر من الجهاز الامني بعد اجراء
تحقيق امني وبيان للطب الشرعي رغم عوده
الهدوء بين طبيعه اعمال الشغب التي قامت
بها مجموعات صغيره تنتقل بين احياء
العاصمه قد يفرض استمرار الاجراءات
الامنيه الى ما بعد صدور تقرير الشرعي حول
سبب وفاه عمار وطي الملف كليا ابراهيم
مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
اعلنت الديوان الملكي الاردني منح الاسنان
السارج وال السيف لقب الاميره رجوى الحسين
وذلك بعد عقد قرانها على ولي العهد ولي
عهد الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
الثاني وشهدت مراسم مع عقد القران في قصر
زهران بالعاصمه عمان حضور قاده وزعماء دول
وضيوف من كافه انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتفقت لجنه الخاصه من علماء الفضاء التي
شكلتها وكاله القضاء الفضاء الامريكيه
ناسا بانه لا يوجد دليل واحد مقنع على
وجود نشاط خارج كوكب الارض وانا نحو 800
مقطع مصور وحادثه تم فحصها ولا يمكن تفسير
هذه الحوادث على انها نشاطا ونشاط لكائنات
فضائيه غريبه
الفضائيون مخلوقات غريبه حياه خارج كوكب
الارض هذا ما يعتقده الكثيرون حيال مقاطع
فيديو وفقها طيارون لاجسام غريبه في
السماء
[موسيقى]
وكاله ناسا لابحاث الفضاء اتفقت على تسميه
هذه الاشياء بظواهر طائرات مجهوله وليس
المخلوقات الفضائيه
البيانات الحاليه وتقارير شهود العيان
وحدها غير كافيه لتقديم ادله قاطعه حول
طبيعه واصل كل حدث غير معروف
مخاوف بشان سلامه السماء السبب الرئيسي
الذي دفع وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه لتشكيل
هيئه تضم خبراء في مجال الفيزياء وعلم
الاحياء الفلكي لدراسه اكثر من 800 حاله
مشاهده لظواهر الطائره غير معروفه
[موسيقى]
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه سبق وان بحثت
حقيقه بعضها بالطائرات المسيره او
البالونات وكاله ناسا اكدت انها لم تعثر
على حياه خارج الارض بعد لكنها تبحث عن
ذلك الكثيرون يشككون في هذه التقارير
ويقولون اننا ستكذب وهناك ما يتم اخفائه
وحول تجربتها علاماتنا المحطه الدوليه
قالت رائده الفضاء السعوديه ريانه برناوي
بانها استمتعت بكل تجربه شاركت فيها خلال
مهمه الفضاء اي اكس تو
العمل مع كيفيه تاثير الجاذبيه على
الوسائط وكيف تتصرف الخلايا وعدد الفقاعات
التي يمكن ان تحصل عليها في انبوب واحد
وما يحصل عندما تكون على الارض تحديدا عند
ضخ الهواء وكيف تختفي كل الفقاعات بالطبع
لا يمكن فعل ذلك في الفضاء لذا فهذه واحده
من الاشياء التي تعلمتها لكنني استمتعت
بكل تجربه عملنا عليها خاصه تجربه استجابه
الحمض النووي الريبوزي لقد كانت تجربه
طويله واستغرقت اياما وحقيقه انه كان لكل
منا دور للمساهمه والعمل عليه واننا كنا
نعمل كفريق واحد كان امرا رائعا
في الخطاب تذكير بابرز العناوين
موجات من المسيرات في طريقها لاستهداف
كيافو رئيس البلديه يؤكد بان انظمه الدفاع
المضاده للطائرات تتصدى لها
رفض سعودي امريكي لانتهاكات الهدنه في
السودان في مواطن تعلن اجراءات عقابيه ضد
الجيش ودعم السريع
مجلس شيوخ يقر قانون رفع سقف الدين وبايدن
يتطلع للمصادقه النهائيه عليه والتحدث
للشعب الامريكي اليوم
في الختام شكرا لحسن المتابعه واعود
والقاكم بعد قليل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات